hi and welcome to my video series of
pyrotechnics explained in five minutes
where I explain the concept in biology
in less than 5 minutes and if you
haven't yet subscribed to my channel
please hit that subscribe button
during installment we'll be talking
about Western blot the Western blot is a
technique which would allow us to detect
our protein of interest in a pool of
protein now nowadays it is like widely
used as a diagnostic tool in many
infectious disease which we'll be
talking about and this is like HIV might
be diagnosed using Western blot so
Western blot has immense importance and
in fundamental research Western blot is
also very important so we would discuss
all these aspects in this video so let's
start how the Western blot works so in
Western blot you have to take your cell
lysate or protein extract or bacterial
extract anything from where you want to
get the protein source so you have to
separate the protein along the molecular
weight in a SDS page gel so the first
degree separation is doing SDS page and
in this situation you separate the
proteins according to their molecular
weight so there would be different
different bands from the protein sample
now your proteins must be lying in these
one of these bands right now this is how
I exactly look like in case of after SDS
page running and stained with Coomassie
blue now the second part of Western blot
is to transfer these proteins into a
PVDF membrane so such that you can
detect your protein of interest let's
say you have via gel and in the jail you
know roughly around 75 KB you have your
protein of interest but the problem is
even if your protein is like 75 KD you
know that you never know what other
proteins are of 75 K be present in that
particular sample so there could be many
different protein which are off
molecular over at 75 KD and present in
the sample
so we doubt
doing a Western blot you cannot tell
whether your protein of interest is
present just on basis of the band size
so what you do in Western blot
you take the gel and for example this is
your you know this is the band of your
interest but it might be some other
proteins as well so what you do is like
you put it in a transfer apparatus where
you put the SDS gel and on top of which
you put PVDF membrane and you transfer
either by chemically or by electrical
field so most popular is electrical
field or electro bond blood these days
so as a result what will happen the
protein is that right now on the jail
would be eventually transferred and
being on the membrane so now once we
have all the proteins in the membrane we
can start to detect our protein of
interest by antibody specific manner so
we need an antibody which can detect our
protein of interest and we have to
understand that that antibody is
monoclonal and it's non not specific to
any other protein it is very specific to
the my protein of interest now on the
membrane there would be several protein
brands and several proteins right so all
of these proteins are present in the
lice it that we have taken now we have
to detect the protein of our interest
that is this particular protein where
the antibody is binding so we would only
get a band in that region
so once the antibody binds we can use
several kilometer Akemi luminescence or
fluorescence based method to detect the
particular protein of interest and most
popular and way of detection these days
are chem illuminants now Western Bart
could be used for diagnosis of several
diseases one big example is AIDS so
let's just take a look how it works so
for example we suspect a patient is
infected by HIV virus so we take the
blood sample of that patient we extract
the proteins and we run it onto a tail
now after that we after running the gel
we take
we blot it and try to detect that our
suspected antigen is present or not for
HIV there are known biomarkers like for
example gp120 is one of the suspected
antigen that has to be present if the
patient is infected by HIV so we have to
blot against that particular protein and
if we see a positive man that means the
patient is infected so for example HIV
virus has gp120 and G p12 against gp120
we could have specific antibodies now we
can detect that specific antibodies in
any of chemiluminescent or colorimetric
way and that would give us distinct band
if we get a man that means the patient
is affected if we don't get a man the
test is negative now not only in
diagnosis or medical usage Western blot
is widely used for studying fundamental
scientific research so in basic cell
signaling could be studied by Western
blot for example let's say imagine our
receptor is activated one muscle again
this bound and there are cascade of
events and most important event is
phosphorylation of these blue protein
so once the phosphorylation of the blue
protein takes place then other nuclear
events and downstream even can take
place so this is a crucial event let's
say so these days we have antibodies
specific to the unphosphorylated protein
versus the phosphorylated epitope so the
phospholipid of antibody allows us to
understand how much phosphorylation has
take place and the degree of
phosphorylation would in turn tell us
about the status of the signaling so in
the plot if we get two bands
corresponding to one the phosphor
epitope and one to the normal immature
then we might say the signaling has
turned on or turned off so based on the
situation of the phosphorylation we can
understand the signaling is turned on or
turned off right so these are the
overall usage of Western blot I mean two
basic examples I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you